where i to do a protest right now i'd
stand up with a sign saying steady
steady on steady as she goes should we
really be doing this think again
question mark very exciting very
exciting
there's hardly anyone on the street
that's going to be like beeping the horn
at me is there and saying well maybe to
get out the way but not to actually say
i want to join this person's movement
and that's the problem conservatism has
darren grimes welcome to the show
thank you very much for having us i'm
dead excited about this one i must see
two northern boys today exactly that's
the way it works hashtag brexit reality
is trending at the moment and people are
upset is this
is this your fault have you done
something here do you know what i don't
think it is my fault this time i can't
say i've spent that much time on twitter
today but i don't think it's me there
there's always some form of brexit
reality right despite the fact there's a
global pandemic sort of wreaking havoc
across the globe as we speak and uh
supply chains have been through it's
fair to say a little bit of rough and
tumble that brexit gets the blame it's
just the way things work on twitter it's
a cesspit of fbpe remains sort of circle
jerkery i'm afraid chris that's the be
all and end all of that it feels like
you're
still kind of one of the big public
enemies around the brexit
debacle i
still had my head up my ass when brexit
was happening i was actually flying back
from
some foreign country while the vote was
going on i was watching it live because
there was nothing else at four in the
morning with the time zone that was in
what was your role in this why do people
have sort of distaste or some some
circles of twitter have distaste for you
when brexit comes up
so i um set up a campaign from my
bedroom in brighton i was at brighton
university at the time and that was 2015
december of 2015
and i set up a campaign called be leave
and it was a liberal-minded brexit
argument that was there to cater to a
younger audience which i thought was
being sort of a little bit left out of
the debate and the argument i thought
there were actually legitimate arguments
to make from a classical liberal
perspective
that simply weren't being made by the
the vote leave campaign
so anyway i set this up and i had just
recently left the liberal democrats
after that because i thought i i cannot
get away from the fact that this party
is unapologetically pro the eu and i
couldn't understand why frankly i i just
i think there are legitimate liberal
arguments for leaving the eu
i
certainly think in many ways the eu on
the world stage has been pretty damn
protectionist and not very
internationalist in its outlook you know
the whole idea of i remember one advert
in particular
where they had a there was a man dressed
up in in asian garb
and there's this woman who's fending
them off and a sort of man who looks
like he's in sort of i don't know saudi
aristocrat dress
fighting off this eu superwoman
and that was an advert calling basically
to try and parrot this idea of the eu as
the protector for of the eu from of eu
countries of the eu 28 at the time
from the rest of the world and i thought
hang on a minute how the hell is that
compatible with any of the arguments
that you know the lib dems parrot every
two minutes about being inclusive and
all the rest of it if anything that's
exclusive
so
i thought about this and i thought well
this is entirely incompatible with
everything that i've heard so far i
thought i was liberal at the time
i i'm not and but i didn't know that i
was quite sort of in my infancy of my
political journey at the time i would
say
um and anyway i set up this campaign
and i think it was pretty quick actually
the the venom in vitriol
i remember the day after the vote i'd
had precious little sleep
i
had been campaigning
for the official campaign for the last
two days out and about you know handing
out leaflets and
knocking on doors and all the rest of it
to try and get out the vote
and
i went into the channel 4 studio
the day after and uh i was met by
sarah morrison who used to be
she was under ted heath former leader of
the conservative party former prime
minister of this country
she was his vice chairman of the
conservative party
and i met her and i thought this is very
exciting you know meeting such a
a grand character within the
conservative history
and uh she was utterly vile i'm afraid
there's no other way of putting it she
said they basically across that panel
said i am thick uneducated i don't know
i didn't know what i was voting for i um
clearly
have i guess betrayed my generation
and that my arguments weren't worth
hearing
and that i think i'm afraid to see
has been what the last
what five years now have all been about
which is this sort of contempt
for those of us who
are conservative minded who quite like
our country
who quite like our monarch who quite
like our flag
who quite like the fact that we should
make decisions in this country and that
we we champion that around the world
that sort of message of being the mother
of parliament's that democracy
and yet all of these things
i think just sort of
you're you're derided as being a
complete neanderthal you know an idiot
that doesn't know what's good for them
let us decide for you that's what you've
been doing all along that's what you've
been voting for you did that with blair
you did that with cameron
you've been doing that for years and
years how dare you
think you know what's good for you and
your community what specifically is it
about you that you think triggered that
talking point because
you know more than 50 percent of the
country voted to leave so there's a lot
of other people that could have been on
the end of that particular shtick
yeah so the 17.4 million people voted
leave and 14 million in the last general
election voted tori and you wouldn't
know that would you by the narrative and
much of the what you hear from the media
class
but i think the contempt for me i think
that i'd go as far to call it hatred
there's a lot of people out there that i
think it's safe to say do not like me
you only have to scroll through one of
me tweets and look at the mentions to
get a get a flavor of that god help you
chris when you post this
interview
but
i think it comes down to this
take a fair few identity boxes
i'm gay
i'm working class i'm from the northeast
and all of these things i did an arts
degree
admittedly i dropped out of it but i did
all of these things suggest
that i should be
a man of the left i should belong to the
left i should recognize
that the tories on for someone like me
or conservatism or brexit
they're not for people like me
you know progressives
own
people like me whatever that means you
know there's this assumption that we're
one homogenous mass
all gay people all trans people all
women all
you name it this rainbow coalition we
all think exactly the same way
when that's obviously complete not a
farce it's a complete not nonsense so i
think the hatred comes from that it's
the fact that i've never known my own
place it's the fact that i've dead have
an opinion and i've dared go against the
grain in that as well you know grandson
of a miner as well how dare i
not recognize what mrs thatcher did the
county durham you know that i've heard
that before
so there are many threads to it i think
it's
ultimately though there's an element of
snobbery to it it does feel like a
heterodox position now to be a young
person like under what 40
and
lean right
and
i only found out not long ago that
20 of the uk population is on twitter
that's it
so even as you say
when there seems to be these pylons and
it's like everyone on twitter hates this
person or everyone on twitter believes
this thing you realize that that at most
even if 100 of people on twitter were
doing it would be one in five of the
entire uk population
yeah exactly but it does feel it does
feel like a heterodox position to be
able to be young and right-leaning
absolutely and that's been a phenomenon
that's been going on for a little while
now but i think brexit has sort of
sped that up by a factor of 10. look i
think all not a lot isn't lost with
conservatism though in i'm not as
pessimistic as most people i think
conservatism has this sort of philosophy
of love as the late and great roger
scrutin once decided uh called it i
think ultimately
what's going to happen is the left are
getting so extreme right the left are
pushing things as far as they possibly
can
where the public are going oh hang on a
minute mate what's going on here and i
think young people eventually will will
have a similar sort of view will come to
ground and say
actually i i really don't like what you
said i think these are being incredibly
divisive
and actually i'm tired of this
and we're at each other's throats like
you wouldn't believe at the moment and
it's a really really nasty environment
um so yeah you're right but there are so
many young people who get in touch with
me and say i'd love to have
conservatives come and speak at my
university but every time i try to do
that it's like clockwork the invitation
will be issued
students that don't like this particular
speaker it could be a democratically
elected member of parliament a
conservative mp
they'll find out about this
they'll kick up a fuss
and the invitation will have to be
cancelled because of the fact that the
venue
has been lost
so you cannot even hear and i say i
repeat 14 million people voted tori in
2019 you cannot hear from a
democratically elected representative of
the people in a university i was
supposedly august universities so to me
it's like well it's no wonder that
people aren't here in conservative
viewpoints in universities and young
people
the young people that aren't going to
uni you know they're out there working
hard they're out there doing their jobs
they're out there making a living
um so
i i can't i it's no surprise to me i i'm
a freak in that sense right being hyper
um plugged in to political debate and
all the rest of it i recognize that i am
i'm not normal but i think we'll get
there eventually because
the left are really really stirring the
pot at the minute and i think that's
gonna have some really nasty
repercussions in the sense of people
will just say
i've had enough with this i'm up to here
with this because we're not electing
these people yet they still keep winning
power they're still winning the cultural
arguments they're still everywhere in
pop culture they're still everywhere in
political culture they're still
everywhere in media culture and i think
people are crying out for diversity of
thought
and um that's the only form of diversity
that i'm afraid to say isn't acceptable
in this day and age i think that you're
right that
there's an interesting paradox going on
here that as in the uk specifically
the
support to the left politically in terms
of how we're getting on in elections
appears to be declining and yet if you
were to look at what's published in the
media it doesn't seem that way at all
but i'm less
hopeful i i'm not sure that i agree
about young people being
maybe having five or ten years and then
being being able to turn around and see
that this is actually more divisive than
it is supporting because the
signal that a lot of the left-leaning
articles are putting off at the moment
is that if you are for the left you are
for compassion
it's acceptance it's tolerance it's a
lot of buzz words that just sound very
easy to consume and man i think
up until i was 27 28 and then probably
still now i'm bro silencing my way
through all of this but i think that
those sort of words just triggering you
in a much less emotionally mature brain
oh well i want that stormzy stormzy
supports [ __ ] whatever he supports
kia stammer like that must be the right
thing amber amber from love island she
supports kiyosama because i'm going to
take my political advice from someone
that went on reality tv
um so
yeah i am
i don't know man
it'll be interesting to wait and see but
i certainly think that one of the
reasons that the talking points are
effective with people that are young
is because
you want to do the thing that seems like
it's good your ability to be skeptical
hasn't fully developed yet and i said
that as someone that has to work very
hard at being skeptical not very
conspiratorially minded really struggle
at sort of poking holes and being
disagreeable with people's arguments
because i presume that most people are
telling the truth and when you've just
stepped out into adulthood your parents
have looked after you for 18 years
you're finally released into the big
wide world to either have a job or go to
university and you think well
mum and dad looked after me yeah most
parents they looked after me they told
me the truth therefore probably most
other adults not only tell the truth but
also know what they're doing
and it takes a lot of time for you to
realize
hang on the competence that i gave to my
parents and presumed that they had
actually doesn't exist with everyone
else in the adult world
i think you're right i think to a
certain extent at least because and that
there is
that's a tale as old as time
conservatism has always had this problem
as i described it earlier conservatism
is the philosophy of love it is this
idea that i actually quite like what
we've done here i want to protect it
what if what we've done here is
something that's disempowering to a
particular group or what if what we've
done here is a mistake
well then
so i would say section 28 was a mistake
right but it was a conservative
david cameron apologized for that in the
obviously a little while later but
certainly in in my political lifetime
and
there is a recognition that that's a
mistake there is a recognition of
well actually maybe we shouldn't have
done that but that's all that's what
politics is all about right i think
there are certain things that within the
conservative tradition that i wouldn't
have been supportive of and some that i
am that for example i think on
environmentalism i think in communities
like this one we are sacrificing or
about to sacrifice
so many working-class jobs on the altar
of the green i've just seen a report
today on hydrogen saying that actually
it's more it fought it was something
that a staggering number a percentage
point more dangerous
by one measure
than gas boilers
and you just think have we thought any
of this through there's just this
narrative that
some technology is coming galloping down
the hill that's just going to save what
and all of a sudden we're going to be
able to have energy aplenty
and you're like what is this what are we
doing why are we setting arbitrary
targets why don't we just say
right yes we want to aspire to have
cleaner air we want
to do that for a multitude of reasons
but one of them being that actually
polluting our air with with this
poisonous stuff and um you know
affecting the the well-being of some of
the british population probably isn't a
net positive thing to do and therefore
we want to do something about that fine
i
i accept that with my full heart what i
don't accept is telling working class
people that you cannot have cheap food
that you cannot have your holidays that
you cannot have your car that you cannot
have
your energy bills cheaper
all of these things right
that you're gonna have to pay to have
your gas boiler removed no no no i say
all of that is a nonsense because we are
what one percent of global co2 emissions
and the likes of china and germany are
still pumped and alcohol like you
wouldn't believe so no i think it's a
complete it's fantasy and it's it's
virtue signal and frankly that's what
they're trying to do with this and you
mentioned it earlier i think the problem
with the environmentalism within the
conservative party within boris's
current number 10 operation
a lot of the thinking is well this makes
us look nice we are the nice people we
can be the nice people
they're never gonna think you're nice
sweetheart wake up buttercup right
they're never gonna think you're nice
conservative and conservatism
aren't
meant to be seen like that
and there's a different there's a reason
for that right you can hold up as an
environmentalist you can hold up a
banner saying um i don't know
resist right
and you think oh resist that sounds very
exciting that's quite tantalizing i'd
have a bit of this where i to do a
protest right now
i'd hand up a site stand up with a sign
saying
steady
you know steady on
steady as she goes
should we really be doing this think
again question mark very exciting very
exciting
there's hardly anyone on the street
that's going to be like beeping the horn
at me is there and saying well maybe to
get out the way but not to actually say
i want to join this person's movement
and that's the problem conservatism has
because it says you know
we actually want to look back through
history we want to actually see what's
working and what isn't we want to
actually think about things before we do
them we don't want to say okay there's a
problem here let's do the most drastic
thing possible
let's cut out cut off our sort of energy
intensive nose to spite our face as
we're doing in
steel manufacturing cement manufacturing
all of these things
the force of what we've done in
northumberland right we've said we're
not going to open a coal mine with about
250 high-skill high-paid jobs
but we are going to get the call that we
need for those bloody big wind farms the
wind turbine things and for the the
cement and steel that we need for boris
johnson's level and up agenda from the
likes of russia the russian bay from the
likes of australia
far-flung countries i love australia
don't get us wrong but the idea that we
should be important things from russia
do you really think they're doing things
cleaner than we could do it in this
country with open cast coal mining with
safe practices you know it's gone are
the days of me granddad going deep down
a pit and not being able to fully extend
his arm
because he's been down there so long
and
just all of these things the
inconsistencies and it's all as i say
just to virtue signal and it's going to
hurt people it's really going to hurt
and i think
there's a really important point chris
really quickly i think that what we saw
in australia in their last general
election where the labor party was
supposed to run home right there was a
they were every poll put them ahead
and it they turned around and said in
places opened in the mining communities
in australia
there will be job losses right because
of our climate change targets
and the people in mining communities in
australia said well actually i'd quite
like to keep my job thanks i'd quite
like to keep pride over what i do pride
in my life pride in my community
and they lost the election i think
that's going to happen it could happen
here in this country i really really do
so i agree that uh tradition isn't sexy
it's very hard it's very hard to glam up
[ __ ] that's been around for
300 500 or a thousand years this quote
from donald kingsbury that i love and he
says tradition is a set of solutions for
which we have forgotten the problems
take the solution away and the problem
often comes back worse than it ever was
before and
i i agree man as i've got older i think
that reinventing the wheel and trying to
go for total upending change is just
we don't do it in any other form elon
musk hasn't decided to try and create a
rocket that can immediately go to mars
he's incrementally made improvements to
an existing model that he's met okay
we'll try this we'll try this and he's
the most revolutionary guy when it when
it comes to this technology yeah so i
think yeah
you're always going to be on the back
foot when it comes to
advertising because there's just not as
much sort of pizzazz going on when it
comes to conservatism um and inevitably
as well that's good you know for a tick
tock generation that likes instagram and
stuff like that and you've got this
bumbling full boris and he's like all
i'm cool and his umbrella's going inside
out and he feels like sort of old
england
i see especially if you're a working
class young person i see why that's not
tremendously seductive on the other hand
you've got dave
the rapper he'll tweet something you
think yeah dave like dave says it so
i'll do what dave says so yeah i do get
that but it'll be it'll be interesting
man i think the uk
the uk is a an interesting case study
because we're so um converse at least in
terms of what the polls have showed to
what happened in america if america had
had the same
trump whitewash that we'd seen an
equivalent sized landslide
to the right um i think that there would
have been a really good case to make
that look all of this sort of identity
wokey stuff it's just it's not
resonating at all with the electorate
but
the flying the ointment the massive
biden-sized flying the ointment is the
fact that that didn't happen
and
that i think has lent four more years of
credence to
more critical race theory more
divisiveness so on and so forth stuff
like that and um
yeah man you see it play out in
everything now i mean did you see here's
another thing i i noticed recently you
see this video of the weightlifter sarah
robles being asked about laurel hubbard
so
she got asked um
what do you think it's this
symbolic
day where
progression and the first trans athlete
is now competing on the stage with you
and there's three female weight lifters
in the 87 kilo category that i think
must be the same category or maybe one
down british girl uh there's sarah
robles and another girl and there's a
nine second silence and then she just
leans forward and presses the button and
goes
no thank you
and then stops what we thought
well apparently she had beat they had
actually asked and said don't ask us any
questions about that particular topic so
it could have been to be fair to them it
could have been a you know next question
i'm not but it did look amazing when i
first watched it and didn't know any of
the the background behind it i thought
you know good for use because it's not
fair
good for use and this is a topic that
actually i've
fallen out
with um a fair few of my conservative
party friends
in the
lgbt tory or whatever it's called now
i'm not sure it is called that anymore
it's lgbtq
i don't even know what that alphabet
soup actually represents anymore but
anyway putting that to one side i've
fallen out with a fair few people over
this very topic
and it's quite sad really because i've
never really understand understood
why people aren't willing to hear you
out because i actually think that my
view on this once you scratch below the
surface
is actually quite nuanced
and
it comes from after watching believe it
or not after watching a bbc
whistleblower report it was bbc news
night and they had this most fantastic
expose of the nhs tavistock clinic which
is the nhs is the uni england's only
gender identity
clinic basically for kids
um and there were kids
that were evidenced in this in
whistleblower reports from people who
had resigned from this clinic which is
now by the way in special measures it's
under investigation
and
they had
heard from kids getting younger and
younger
and each time the case for medical
intervention supposedly getting stronger
and stronger
and these kids were saying things like
well
you know i just don't like my body
well
some parents got coming out and saying
uh
i would prefer a trans outcome over a
gay outcome
and you hear some of these stories
and i actually felt really upset
i actually felt
the people who are calling me you know
transphobic online and things like that
i don't think that's right i think for
some of these kids
you you don't need medical intervention
you need a hug sweetheart you know you
need you need some you need to actually
be able to sit down with someone
and have some therapy and discuss these
things and if in the future
you know when you're old enough
and you can decide to to have a life
changing life altering medical procedure
like that
i've got no problem with that whatsoever
you know if you if that's going to make
you feel better feel happier
feel more at home in yourself then happy
days and that's the same position as
someone like jk rowling she only said
the only thing she said
was that she has deep reservations
about what's going on as far as
self-identification is concerned so you
know if you chris decide that you are
now christine and in the gym lamarra
you're gonna walk into the girls
changing room and have a good old time
in there then
you know she said i think that's gonna
present some problems
and most people at home watching this
will be thinking well i i agree
but if they're not
i asked them to look a bit deeper at
what she was saying because in this
essay that she published on our website
that caused much hysteria
she actually was saying i was a victim
of domestic violence in the past i had
to use a women's refuge
it to me
single sex spaces must be protected
and i know people you know what places
like this there's a lot of alcohol
misuse
i've known people go that have gone
through domestic violence horrible as it
is
and
you you just think
i cannot imagine a more vulnerable
position
one for children to be placed in we've
seen over recent days a therapist
who volunteered at child line for the
last five years he james esses he's lost
his position as as a volunteer for and
his degree his qualification
from for the crime of actually saying
well i think actually we shouldn't be
just affirming that these kids have
gender dysphoria
we should actually be saying to them
well i want to have a few sessions with
you i want to talk things out and see if
there are anything else that's
underlying your
the issues that you feel that you're
having at the minute and you think well
again that's sensible jk rowling saying
i i really worry about sex segregated
spaces as someone who had used them
myself as someone had who had to use
women refuge myself
and you think well again that sounds
sensible
but these people are derided and
cancelled jk rowling hasn't been
cancelled because she's too rich to be
cancelled too successful to be cancelled
but someone like james s has been
for saying actually i'm too worried
about the kids i've seen that are
getting younger and younger
but the the sort of methodology that's
been pushed at them is getting more and
more severe
each time
i definitely think i definitely think
that there's a difficulty in justifying
how someone that legally can't have sex
is able to change their sex that to me
seems like look if if you're not
trusting them to
i must stop you there sorry
well i mean
those those two words used to be
interchangeable uh
yes
those people who want to change their
gender are too young to have sex but can
change that gender that seems like you
can't give somebody responsibility
over
one thing that is an immutable change
for the remainder of their life and
another thing that is going to happen in
any case like i i don't know that seems
that seems backwards i think the the
interesting thing about the olympics
question for me was that it now
there is no place in the world which is
not open to being used as a platform for
political debate that like look i know a
lot of weightlifters they work really
really really hard it's an incredibly
fatiguing sport their central nervous
system is almost always fried if they're
training close to maximally in the
build-up toward a competition
they're they're probably not spending
that much time thinking about the finer
points and even if they were even if
they have done it like these people are
good because they're athletes
they're not supposed to be you know the
the insights for sense making
at level 1000 that's not why we go to
them we go to them because they're able
to lift heavy things
like
i don't know i just feel like there was
that that gymnast as well that did the
black lives matter fist at the end of
her gymnastic routine and you think well
i don't know like
what sort of an example i i can't work
out if that's a good example to set for
young athletes that look you have a
platform and visibility therefore do it
or if it's like look
get on with doing your sport like be
good at the thing that you're supposed
to be there for
absolutely i mean the the hubbard
example
i think calls into question so many
things hubbard of course lost right
hobart didn't actually
qualify and get through to to to become
a medalist
and i say well you know god bless those
girls that did and women that did um
because it must have been you must just
be thinking
how unfair i feel so sorry for the kiwis
that didn't get through that ms hobart
took the position of because
i think
ultimately biological sex is an
immutable fact you know i i'm born a man
if i decide that i want to live life as
doreen and i have medical intervention
to to go about that
i'm still going to be
a biological male
i still have
gone through puberty i still have all of
the that well probably you more than me
chris let's be honest about this but you
know i still have
more strength than than a male of a
female counterpart so there are so many
ways and this calls into a question of
fairness and that's that's where i'm at
on all of that
but
on the politicization of sport that's a
really really interesting one i've got
myself in some hot water about
criticizing um sportsman yeah
not too distant past
um
and it is an interesting one and i think
the blm feast
is probably
a naked attempt to get some sponsorship
deals
you know you can find yourself in a nice
cover
raising your face and people young
people think oh good goody goody this is
virtuous how amazing how fantastic even
though of course that symbol the fist
has been a symbol of communist terror
and tyranny throughout history communism
of course been an ideology that has been
responsible for murder unique throughout
the world billions not millions of
people and yet still
apparently this is the new symbol of
progressive virtue signaling politics
did you have a second thought about the
tweet that you sent to marcus rashford
obviously you're someone who's been the
target of some some pretty mean stuff
online and i imagine that if you just
failed on a very tall stage
and you'd gone online there's almost a
zero percent chance that marcus did see
that but i'm sure that it wouldn't have
made you feel good if the equivalent had
happened to you have you reflected on
this
yeah no i think i think you're right i
think that's a fair criticism i think
that uh i certainly wouldn't have
enjoyed that very much
but you know everything that happened
with with marcus that sort of little run
that he did up to the the ball and it
was just like it's the showmanship it's
the
it's the
the well of course the politics which
we're discussing we can discuss
and
and people saying well oh you must be
pro starving children i mean chris i
went to school on i had free school
meals myself right
we we struggled my mom got divorced when
uh i was still at school and
uh she had to remortgage the house and
everything we were going through
financial difficulties had to turn to a
food bank at one point i'm not someone
who isn't supportive of charity and
isn't supportive of
looking after kids i am someone who's
critical of
i think
get an abolishing what is slowly
happening the abolishment of the role of
the parent that really worries me
and and i think that's increasingly
happening actually there's now a sort of
a view that even
getting your kids eyes tested oh well
the school should do that that's the
school's responsibility teaching your
kid a read no that's the school's
responsibility
there's this
i guess devolving
of your responsibility as a parent
if you if you're not willing to teach
your kid how to read you shouldn't be a
man or dad if you ask me that's my view
and some people won't like that but at
this point i couldn't care less but yes
the one thing i do regret
is is the the tone i guess of that tweet
the
the i guess it could have come across as
being mean spirited but i still i'm
afraid i still stand by that i don't
like politics in sport
you know i want i want rashford to be
winning for england
i'd like to be doing a little less
winning for for manchester but apart
from that you know i'd like him to to be
to be doing his sport playing because
you're right there's a politicization of
everything now i mean the bbc
this morning
posted out from bbc women the bbc women
account quite why there's a bbc women
account i don't know
but they posted out saying
that
is it right
sort of asking for questions or comment
on the debate about showing children
pornography
to teach them about consent and other
issues didn't someone from gb news get
annihilated about this only last week
yes i think so yeah so there's a i mean
there's been a fair few little bits
about this coming out and about and i
think the reason why the bbc actually uh
ran this is because it was someone it
was amber rudd's daughter
had tweeted
something to that effect saying i think
a good idea to teach kids about consent
you know would be to to do this to
advocating it and she quickly deleted it
does does porn assist with consent
like what what do you highlight how does
porn teach anybody about consent i think
that i think the the
actually contained within this thread
i it wasn't a logical thread i mean an
actual thread on twitter
and it basically said well there
wouldn't be any choking of things like
that and you think my god was any would
anyone really propose that with burns
with kids with children
what what world are we living in what
sick twisted reality that also presumes
as well that choking can't be consensual
which is also wrong yes of course but i
still think that children shouldn't be
those things porn and children
just
like if you're thinking if anybody
that's listening to this is thinking
got this idea about
sort of porn
and children i might tweet about it just
that those are two of these sort of red
boxes and you're like nah if if those
two things are in the tweet just don't
put it out
the final ultimate taboo is anything
around underage
kids and sex like absolutely it is it is
the one that no matter where you stand
there is not a single person that's
going to be on your side so doing that
just seems like it just seems so dumb
and then yeah for bbc three a bit
whatever bbc women to tweet out about
you like what
what are we achieving here like really i
mean
i don't know man i don't know here's
another one so twitter again uh owen
jones trending today i've had an idea
because i come from an event background
how do you feel about uk political
commentary
celebrity boxing
and then
maybe owen jones douglas murray because
i'd pay
very good money to watch that happen you
on this very show were talking to
douglas about his exercise routine about
what he's been doing with his arms and
that he's got some pretty serious arms i
really think he could take on jones on
um not that i've been admiring douglas's
arms with with any great uh depth
wink wink um but i i think that's
probably a good idea can any idea
because actually the problem is with
people like owen jones and and others
like them they're just not willing to
engage with with people on the other
side of the argument they think that
i go back to roger scrutin again
actually which is roger scrutin said
that i don't think the left or evil i
just think they're mistaken and that's
the difference between me and you know
the likes of owen jones he genuinely
thinks that people like me are evil scum
of the earth that's a very nice
distinction it's a really nice
distinction between malice being
purported from one side about the other
and ignorance or negligence being
purported about the other side back i
think that's probably a pretty good way
to characterize it it is it's a nice
wave i mean they would argue that
actually it's the other way around
probably right you know these well mean
and virtue signaling
tosses i was about to say
but um you know
each to their own i i i would be more
than happy to to meet with owen jones
and and have a paint with him in a
discussion with him but i doubt that's
going to happen anytime soon
little nas x he's got a new song out
which is kind of like the
gay
male equivalent of whap of the whap
video have you seen this video i haven't
seen the video i'm afraid no i have seen
the video right okay so it's kind of
like that but it's in a prison and it's
all men
instead of instead of all women and lil
nas x and his his backup dancers are
completely naked but and then there's
sort of blurred
blurred over the top of the areas that
matter and um
i was just quite surprised because when
whap came out that it was so provocative
and maybe the lyrics were a tiny bit
more provocative but
yep it sort of created this furor online
about women empowering being empowered
by their own bodies and stuff like this
and
not being an object for the male gaze
it's sort of where we taking control of
our personal sovereignty and stuff like
that and we haven't seen the equivalent
with
a man also doing it for the male gaze
uh we haven't seen the same with that i
don't really know why and i wondered uh
given your
sexual predilection if you had a unique
insight into this
i i think there's with gay men there is
a lot of deep-rooted shame with a lot of
gay men still i think there's a lot of a
sense of
actually
and one thing i find quite sad
is
this idea that i think there's a lot of
gay men who i'm gonna get very deep here
i'll get me violin out there's a lot of
gay men who don't think for example that
sort of they don't recognize any form of
self-worth i think they could do with
listening to a lot of your sort of
motivation and positive thinking mantra
because i think there's a lot of people
who have been made to feel shame
throughout their life i think that's
still like my brother's generation he's
uh 80 years younger than i am i think my
brother's generation
have have had it different at school to
to what i did at school and that's a
pretty fast trajectory you know things
have changed at breakneck speed so i
think future generations won't have that
problem whether or not
you need to
do i need to bring
sort of
show off my bits dangly bits to to feel
liberated i don't i don't necessarily
think that's that's true i think to feel
liberated
i need to feel
like a
ordinary member of society that's why i
supported same-sex marriage i want to be
as boring as all of you straight people
right i want to be able to walk around
and i come from that i guess old
tradition of of gay men that actually
just want to be born that actually just
want to
this they would they would say that i'm
pandering to hetero
being heteronormative i think is what
they call it and i'd say well no i just
want to live life you know i just want
to be accepted by society be a part of
society
uh and i don't think that
it's necessary to to put out music
videos like that i'm just not sure what
you gain from it to be honest with you
so i understand the uh the desire not to
have your sexuality as the
first and foremost part of your
personality like i definitely understand
that i think the thing that was quite
interesting was uh something douglas
said on the show where he said you
realize that you have true equality when
you have to put up with the same level
as [ __ ] as everybody else
and
that um lack of special treatment i
actually think quite at least i only
found out about this video seven days
after it was released it's had like 200
some ridiculous number of views it's
number two trending on youtube at the
moment and it's been out for a week and
i only found out about it in the sauna
chatting to a mate yesterday so
it's completely slipped by me and i'm
usually fairly active online looking for
interesting stories
so that was like okay well cool that is
a rapper releases a music video
and in it he's naked
and he's gay
and his fans care but nobody else does
i'm right okay that's progress that
really does feel like progress nobody
gives a [ __ ] like that's the level
indifference
is the level that everybody should be
aiming for with equality i think
yeah i mean there's a certain extent to
which i think we're sort of taking
things everything is sex these days you
know you've got love island you've got
um what too hot to handle on netflix
you've got these music videos you've got
i i just sort of think
that there's
probably such a thing as too much sex
right i'm not sure why
we we are so obsessed with this
now and to what extent
the the sort of
i guess children are being
you know brought up i remember we used
to watch music videos
in the the sort of common room at school
to what extent we did have a common room
and um
uh
you you would watch them back to back
and i'm thinking
god
the kids that are watching music videos
these days you know back in my day when
i don't know the sugar babes were
bobbing about on a stool it's quite
different these days when people are i
don't know pattern themselves and you
just think good god what are kids
watching i it's why i'm turning into a
really old fart dude maybe this is part
of the reason why increasingly people
are needing
there's a
an insight that some young people need
to learn about sex sooner i mean taking
the porn thing out of it like kids are
being sexualized sooner because it's at
the forefront of everyone's conversation
at the moment
but then it doesn't really seem to be
about the thing that everybody's
actually bothered with like no one's
ever actually talking about how to find
a good relationship about how to make it
work long term which ultimately is the
like yeah
sure enough you need to find someone
sexually who's compatible with you you
need to work out what your sexuality is
and so on and so forth but all of that
is in service presumably with you
actually finding someone that you're
going to be happy with because if you're
still playing the dating game at 50
years old
not many people are going to look at
that and consider it a success in the
dating world so all of this is in
service of basically relationship
building but i'm not hearing anybody
talk about that because
too conservative too old school marriage
is an archaic institution it's
heteronormative it's it's patriarchal
cisgendered
it's oppressive yeah i certainly think
in sex and relationship education you
should be talking about those things you
should be talking about well this is how
people
in a normal loving relationship are
actually tread because you know i i mean
the number of kids at my school that had
to drop out for a bit because they'd
ended up pregnant you know uh and you
just think
god that's that's one that's no life for
that that ben right who's gonna be
brought up by a child
um and
i hope they're all right of course i
wish them well
but um
there are so many ways in which
i wish in schools we weren't talking
about well this is this is just i don't
know
this is what a trans person is this is i
think there was an example with trans
penguins or something or gay penguins or
something like that
you can't escape the fact that gay
people exist in this day and age you
know you turn on netflix you turn on
your chat show you turn on whatever
you're gonna see that gay people exist
right i'm not sure schools need to be
doing it i think what schools do you
need to be doing
is actually saying the kids you can be
something you can achieve something with
your life
especially in areas like this
you know you can actually if you work
hard if you stick in at school
you can achieve something this is a
country where you can still do that
where hard work actually has results
meritocratic
instead of thinking which i think to a
large extent for a lot of my life i did
as well which is you are stupid you
cannot you know there's no point in
trying
i remember my maths teacher saying it
was um
when you feel
when you feel
it's not going to be my fault
he said it's it's going to be on you
it's the most passive aggressive maths
teacher that i've ever heard of oh
absolutely but it stuck with us for
obvious reason but then another and the
the you had these stupid waste of time
sort of counselors that would come in
and say oh what is it you want to do
with your life um and he said oh well
with you know if if those are your
project predicted grades you're not
going to get into a university and stuff
like that now i think we're sending as
it happens far too many people at
university
but i'd still like to kids to hear that
if you want to do that you can do it you
know what you've got to do though you've
got to stick in you've got to work hard
and that means revising at home that
means not going out and about with your
mates getting drunk in a park
not saying i did that and all of these
things you know that's not
thinking about girls and boys quite so
early that's not
all the rest of it i think there's a
real problem with aspiration with kids
and communities up and down the uk
definitely in the uk definitely in the
uk man so i was having this conversation
with an american and we were talking
about
one of the problems that the american
culture has is when these young kids get
older because the american dream still
very much sort of is alive you can be
whatever you want to be that sort of
american dream is still yours even if
that dream is kind of changing i think
the encouragement's still there whereas
in the uk it's a lot more tall poppy
syndrome you know coming from a state
school if you talk a little bit
differently if you sound a bit
differently if you have different
interests or whatever like it's it's a
it's a tough road and
what you get from the advantage that you
have in the uk of that is that you don't
ever believe you're on [ __ ] but the
problem is you don't ever believe that
you can be worth anything exactly so you
do get two sides of the coin we're
brought down to earth and this is why i
think you're seeing
the
super progressive um talking points just
not land quite so well in the uk because
we're quite salt of the earth people
generally
especially the place that mean you were
from you know the northeast of the uk no
one's bothered about that it when you're
concerned about your next paycheck and
keeping the the lights on you don't have
time to worry about gendered pronouns
and bathrooms and stuff like that
um but the disadvantage you get is you
don't have as much encouragement and you
know that's something for the people
that have got younger brothers and
sisters like that's your role i'm an
only child so i never had the
opportunity to do that but that's your
role 100 to be the person that gasses
them up like tell them that they can do
stuff because they can i mean like the
number one desired job
of
primary school kids now is youtuber like
that's the most desire not policeman not
firemen and you know
maybe we're making this situation worse
but
uh i definitely think that if that's the
case then you literally can do it
anybody can do it there's like kids that
are making millions reviewing toys and
stuff like that but i bet that there's
still the same tall poppy syndrome
challenge going on there so yeah that
was if i could change something about
the uk one of the top
parts of the culture that i would do
is this
desire to
mock or sort of drag people down that do
non-typical pursuits absolutely
definitely and that's why we need to
start talking about more things like
technical education you know one of my
brothers is uh works in distribution for
a supermarket you know pulling pulling
out loads from factories and things like
that all day long um and he's in and out
of work like that and if for someone
like him he would have really been able
to benefit from a technical education
and it's interesting that you mentioned
being a single child because i actually
think you know a lot of a lot of my what
i'm passionate about comes from
my experience with watching my brothers
who have gone through
exactly the same upbringing but with
very different sort of pursuits
and
so for him technical education
and i think for me other brother grammar
school education you know there are i
think it's i'm so passionate and so of
the view that school choice and a
diversity within education
is is the way we go about actually
you put like-minded kids together and
you say all right well you're interested
in this you're gonna be passionate
you're gonna give it your all that's
fantastic for kids
let's do more of that and let's give
people the the chance to
actually think i'm not stupid i can
actually i am good at something you know
that there's something here i'm
passionate about and make them feel that
they can do something and achieve
something with the lives because far too
many people in in places like this and
it's it's utterly horrible i know a fair
few people from school
who have gone in to just you know
basically being alcoholics or or drug
addicts and
it's it's sad to see it's so sad to see
too much pain that's the problem too
much well maybe it's true maybe it's the
poor night too much porn in school i
think that's really that might be a big
part of it i've been thinking a lot
recently i put a tweet out earlier on
saying i want to bring someone on the
show and josh rogan has has reached out
to talk about china and sort of their
long-term
political and global plans
but can you imagine
what do you think is the difference
between the
culture
of the uk and the usa over the last 16
months
that has occurred
and the culture that russia and china
would have wanted to happen if they
wanted to begin the disintegration of
those two countries
yes well a culture that's basically
eaten itself where at each other's
throats you know it really does feel
like that
it actually feels like
the sort of environment and i've heard
this said before the sort of environment
that you'd expect before
a sort of especially in america
civil war you know where people really
are
that is d legitimate uh
i guess the delegitimization
of an election
um you've got
people arguing all over that of course
you've got people arguing over kamala
harris is one of the most unpopular vice
presidents in quite some time that's a
really interesting uh statistic i think
there are so many ways in which kind of
the flag like self-hatred of the flag
like that's literally the symbol of your
country
and that's a symbol of for many people
throughout the world who
really really want to be
in part of american life american values
who look at that flag and think oh wow
the freedom and liberty you know when my
grandad um served in korea in their 50s
and alongside the americans and
australians and gurkhas and a few others
but he
looking at the the american flag looking
at the the our own flag looking at the
union jack i dare say that they looked
at those flags and felt immense pride in
what we
they were doing because look at south
korea now it's a beacon of freedom of
hope and prosperity
and
you look at them in north korea
a different example and you think wow
life there
not for me going to be honest looks
pretty grim pretty tough pretty horrible
and you think well done you granddad i'm
proud to know you man
and
you think you look at the petulant
pratts
today
turning their backs on flags like the
two of those i've just mentioned the
american or the uk flag
there we are we have a a period of
self-loathing going on at the minute
that'll have the chinese and russia
rubbing them hands with glee they must
be delighted by this
they must be
thrilled because it that's the only way
i can describe it hatred
there is a deep-rooted resentment of
your own country and i don't understand
it and that's why i say conservatives
and this is the philosophy of love
because there is certainly none of that
on our side at the argument it seems to
be exclusively coming from the so-called
progressives and to me there's nothing
progressive there's nothing that's going
to leap lead us forward
about this self-loathing about this
everything my country does must be bad
and douglas has said this before i think
he said it on your show where
if someone if a person that you know
does not have your best interests at
heart says to you chris you should be
doing x you should be doing this
i think what you're doing now is really
bad
bit shite
you're gonna say oh well um i'll take
that with a pinch of salt me because you
don't have my best interest at heart i
think that's exactly what we should be
doing with these people who sneer at our
flag who do not wish our nation well
who seem to want to see it fail at
almost any opportunity it's like
gaslighting like nations nation-sized
gaslighting you're being taught like i'm
i'm hitting you but i'm only hitting you
because i love you and then it's almost
like when you get that stockholm
syndrome of the person they say look
like i stay with them for this reason
and it just appears to be
self-perpetuated
hatred coming from somewhere and i found
this out uh i can't remember who it was
that i was speaking to but
i've found out that the largest
black lives that pro black lives page on
facebook before
blm was started by the internet research
internet research agency in russia like
it was that was who began the page so
you think okay what are the chances that
at least let's say that it's
10
of the last year's
um
violent and vociferous problems have
come from those sorts of agents what if
it was the first 10 what if that was the
pebble at the top of the avalanche and
then you just allow people to do the
social media thing so going back to the
the england um football analogy
the the the way that the press decided
to perpetuate narratives about racism
after the match now i don't want that
those idiots absolutely morons that the
people that decided to tweet that stuff
online or contact the players or deface
murals and stuff like that but
i don't feel too good about what the
press did either because all that did
was they said look
the headline of we played well but
unlucky we didn't win it isn't going to
generate that many clicks but
look at these closet racists from
romford and blythe and you know carlisle
and all of these working-class towns we
always knew that this was the case and
now they finally had their opportunity
to do it and then to perpetuate it for
days and days and days you think that
well
what's this achieving like is it do you
think this is for the betterment of the
country is it is it educating people on
on racism or is it using fringe examples
to limbically hijack people and then
after you've limitly hijacked them are
you just creating more divisiveness
within it i mean you did see a really
good response as maybe you could say
from that you saw this sort of beautiful
presentation on rashford's mural where
people went and they made this really
sort of nice display where it was fixed
and and people showed love but i think
you probably could have got away with
that with just one story i don't think
you would have needed to keep it going
for a full week well actually the
rashford memorial at the matt rashford
mural rather memorial is is actually
important because of the fact that the
police had to release a statement saying
that they didn't think that it was
racism there was no sort of racist
graffiti on the the mural and it's just
like you you take bad penalties or
something but something like that i
don't know it wasn't me i promise and um
you look at these
things and you think well hang on a
minute because this was this was going
round and round on twitter you had
people stand next to this mural on then
bended knee
black lives matter posters and things
like that
and you're thinking well hang on a
minute it had the police have just told
whether it had subtle to do with racism
and it had everything to do with some
you know some silly bugger just graffiti
and i've probably been a bit miffed
about the footy match that it just being
played in and you think well why would
they do that hmm that's interesting
and it's it's to stir up
that divisiveness
it's exactly what we on the conservative
right get accused of all the time they
stirring up of hatred you know oh you
hate hateful speech and all the rest of
it i'm sorry but i think the ones that
are stirring up hatred here are those
trying to perpetuate they push this
narrative of racist old blighty you know
post brexit britain backwater that it is
racist backwater doesn't like immigrants
doesn't like people footballers that
play well like marcus rashford which is
it's palpable nonsense i mean the number
of people
if i look back throughout my life i kind
of think of many examples
where i've i've heard of
racism directed at at footballers
because of the fact that people don't
seem to care much about the color of the
skin of the footy players on the pitch
they just care about the fact that the
footy players no matter what their color
no matter what their their sexuality
they are
good on the pitch
they can perform well for their teams
that the color of their skin their
immutable characteristics has absolutely
subtle to do with their performance
and you think is a country like that
racist and you're right all of the
examples of racism tend to they seem to
come from abroad with you know what i
think it was even bbc news nice that
looked into that and found those
statistics
and then you look a bit further and you
think well hang on what's going on here
why are they why are people doing this
why is this happening why is my country
having this
you know all as you say all of these
newspapers there was a collective sort
of circle jerk of hysteria over this
stuff
saying nasty britain
horrible racist blighty
and that's
we have fallen to such a large extent if
we genuinely have pockets of society
that the those that are publishing the
news stories those that are tweeting
those that are and you mentioned there
that 20 of people on are on twitter you
mentioned that earlier
20 is actually quite disproportionately
high if you can compare it with the
likes of india for example if you
compare it with other economies
it's actually quite high
there are a lot of british people on it
compared to other countries around the
world
and you think
as far as the the cultural clout that
twitter has in this country as well
tweets will end up in papers
right tweets will make news
tweets will decide the headlines of
stories
and
you think
why are these people
so self-loathing and that's something i
cannot answer i was going to say have
you got any impression about why because
i i understand
in the first instance that limbically
hijacking people is good for traffic
because things that you really agree
with are things that you really hate
both [ __ ] that you're gonna click on
that makes sense um
but it just feels like there was it felt
like there was more going on than that
it was just so perpetuated over and over
and over again i don't know whether it
was a slow week for news um maybe maybe
they genuinely do the people in the bbc
or the guardian or whoever's commenting
on this stuff maybe they genuinely do
believe that this is um
such a
a righteous
cause
that they do need to continue talking
about it because people need to know and
they haven't known enough just yet and
i mean that's the best if that's the
best interpretation this sort of oddly
paternalistic
uh view of the world and then from there
it's just like china and russian agents
and share bots all the way down as far
as i can see it just gets potentially
worse and potentially worse and
potentially worse and um yeah man i i
want to find out about this
about this china stuff because the small
insight that i've had in what russia is
doing at the moment is terrifying and it
just feels like it feels to me like
there's something else going on it feels
like
i
my real world experience doesn't match
up with the things that i'm seeing on
the internet and the stories that are
being noted like i've met a million
people on the front door of nightclubs
i've watched a million people go in and
out of events that i've done i must have
seen
maybe two things that are racist ever
that's in 15 years
a million people but there is no sample
size that's going to be bigger than that
and i stand on the door so i see when
the black bouncer drags
a white customer out for being too drunk
or having a fight or snogging someone in
the corner or whatever i see when that
happens and this white guy
could be in reverse has got every reason
in the world to be very very angry at
this person they've just lost their
night they've away from all their
friends they've had a little bit of
booze and even in that sort of the most
bass
un
filtered version of ourselves like the
least gracious nature of ourselves comes
on nights out
even then
i don't see it
i'm like if that's not the situation in
which it's going to happen
so i don't know i just i i really think
that the last 16 months one of the main
things that i've learned is to be
increasingly skeptical not only of the
people that are in power
but of the things that i see in the
press and this may be like the mate you
know the michael malus is the world who
messed you and going you were an idiot
like why were you ever believing this in
the first place but again like you know
if you the sort of person that's a bit
orderly and has faith in institutions
you don't think that there's something
to bring up you don't usually consider
that maybe they don't have my best
interests at heart but like holy [ __ ]
man like this last year has completely
eroded any of my trust
in
legacy media and in the people that are
supposed to be in power but it's
interesting that you mentioned that that
line there about middle class
people who are paternalistic because it
see it just strike me as a really
patronizing view like oh well actually
what what um
racial arguments and and tensions need
is me to patronize people and say i know
what's good for you you know i i don't
i'd i'd like to hear more conversations
from i don't know black mothers for
example in the likes of london that are
saying to to these middle class liberals
who are clutching their pearls and
saying we must stop stop and search
because it disproportionately affects
certain communities in this country
there are mothers who are being
interviewed about this stuff and they're
saying i like stop and search i won't
stop and search because actually it's
making me feel like my child is safe
that my child might actually stand a
better chance of coming home tonight
and you look at you hear that argument
here the fear imagine fearing that your
child's not going to come home because
they're going to be stabbed to death
imagine being a black mother of a young
kid
and realizing that the potential reason
that your now dead child
didn't make it home is because somebody
sat in
westminster
or somebody that was at the guardian put
enough political pressure on to say this
is discriminatory and again like it does
come back like it's
for me the more that i think about it
especially over the last year there were
certain things that needed to be done
very quickly
there were things that required rapid
and
un
uh
unmolested progress
in order to be able to keep up with the
pace of change that was happening in the
world but it doesn't need to be spread
across everything and i really do think
what was what did your sign say steady
on or something well
yeah steady just the word steady yeah so
i do think you know test things away i
mean have you seen this refund the
police now so the studies came out in
america that said that last year murders
are at uh an all-time high from the last
30 years it was a 20 or 25 year-on-year
increase largest since the mid-90s and
so far this year it's 15 up on top of
that and all of the researchers every
single one of them seems to agree that
police presence is the best way to
reduce homicides
and i mean the number of police officers
in dc that have killed themselves from
that one force that i haven't seen
what's this that got involved with the
capital what happened at the capitol
building with the
the uh
i guess storming of the capitol building
yeah they've been
at at least
five it like i think it's six now
suicides
of these police officers killing
themselves and you think what sort of
thing are they what sort of abuse are
they getting and i that sort of has me
thinking who in their right mind would
want to be a copper in this day and age
you know who in their right mind would
want to do that it doesn't
it strikes me as eminently sensible that
police officers in this day and age
quite like the fact that they can some
of them at least and this isn't a stress
it's not the vast majority of them but
some of them can sit on in offices
registering non-crime hate incidents the
most orwellian thing i've ever been part
of really um or ever fallen victim of
and
i i sort of think good god you people
you know you don't deserve any of this
that the stress and the
[ __ ] frankly that you have to put up
with on a daily basis no wonder you'd
rather sit in the office and i i don't
know take off non-crime hate incidents
and look into them and say nothing to
say here gov you know this sort of stuff
is cartoon i think the priorities of the
west have
across the west even have become so far
removed from the actual concerns of
people on the ground you know i've just
mentioned that people really concerned
about the kids coming home on a night
time especially in places like london
you've got kids in scotland man who
aren't leaving school with the ability
to read and write
and you think it's 2021 i don't know why
i've just looked at the time it's 2021
and you've got kids leaving school with
in an ability to read and write
and and they're talking about
independence and things farting around
with this sort of thing
the priorities of many politicians and
and these sort of influences in the
middle class liberals with the perpetual
guilt i think it is i've met so many
attorneys you know they're really
annoying there's always so patrician
there tends to be and this isn't all of
them of course but many attorneys
there's this idea of guilt like oh i
should feel ashamed of my
of what the accident of birth that led
me to have such a wonderful privilege in
life no you shouldn't
you should just go out there and do
something with your life what happens
downstream from that so let's say that
this person no but genuinely i'm asking
this person is born they have this guilt
how do they how does that change the way
that they behave that manifests itself
in them being sort of very patrician in
outlook so you know like oh i know
what's good for people they should do x
y and z and there's this sort of um
idea that actually people don't have
agency over their own lives and that you
know you need people like us who who can
actually do it for you who can tell you
what's good for you and all the rest of
it so they think they're doing good but
actually they're not then they're really
really being quite condescending to
people and if there's one thing i've
noticed especially in the northeast as
you will well know there is nothing that
people like worse than feeling that
they're being spoken down to and i think
that's why the political class got such
a punch in the nose in 2019 in that a
general election where
large swathes of voters who have never
voted tori before said you know what
i'm gonna get yours this time like um
i've had enough how dare you talk to me
like that the anger that i heard over
the last five years my inbox being
flooded with people saying thank you so
much for what you're saying i can't
believe i'm being spoken down to and
lectured like this patronized like this
from what is essentially a middle-class
technocracy a middle-class
view of saying things like well
we need to go back to you being told by
tory tops what's good for you and do you
see that on the climate change debate as
well right we've got oh you can't that
gas boiler love no sheila we're going to
pull that out for your pet don't worry
how much oh don't ask questions like
that 20 grand how much and you said you
think what the
is going on here there is so much i
think that there are so many problems in
the world and i think most of them are
down to middle class liberals who feel
guilty that's that's my theory actually
strongly so that doesn't surprise me
that that's your theory yeah i am
i don't know man i i was talking the
other day to jpc and he used to be a
life coach and he was saying that um
empathy is actually a very narcissistic
emotion because when you're caring about
other people in that way what you're
presuming is without me your life is
going to suffer so much and that i think
that sort of maybe there is a little bit
of guilt of being born
with
more access to resources or a better
education and stuff like that and
perhaps that does trickle down
to these people thinking
well
what i need to do what my duty is is to
bestow
this gated information that me and my
friends are the only ones that we that
we have access to but the dumb thing is
especially you know coming from a
working-class background and state
schools like we both have
like
i arrived at university and met people
from private school for the first time
i'd never met anyone from a private
school really prior to that i'd just
been at state schools and i looked at
the people who arrived at newcastle uni
a red brick a proper university and i
saw
just as many if not more fuck-ups
come from the people that had been away
at boarding school
like uh pocklington hymers you know all
of these like sort of middle yorkshire
really expensive schools boarding 30
grand a year plus and they ca they came
and they were just as [ __ ] as
everybody else like they didn't have
they didn't have their stuff sorted at
all
and um yeah presuming that
levels of education
imbue you with some sort of better moral
sense
i think
at the very least is probably inaccurate
and actually might run in the opposite
direction oh yeah absolutely because if
what you quickly find right is with and
i've noticed this as well i hadn't met
anyone really until i moved down south
until i went to brighton anyone that
went to private school because i'd
worked in
at the only my jobs were working in a
supermarket and working in a
hairdresser's right you don't meet many
people i went to private schools in
those sort of lines of work and um i i
thought it was like another world and
you think
you talk to some people and they're
they just they're so infantilized
because they haven't had and this this
isn't i'm generalizing massively and
i've got many friends who went to
private schools and they are not like
this
but
there there's this sort of
infantilization where the kind of a
person that i assume you're talking
about at newcastle uni
would be the sort of person that is like
oh my word there's this look how cheap
the drinks are right there's this sort
of
new castle man three troubles for five
pounds fifty catch up come on and the
like bends in sort of sweet shops right
and
you're just you're like looking at them
like
what world have you been living in like
what world have you experienced so i
think that you're right there's there's
definitely a minority of people that
will like that um and the the worst
culture that i saw and this may trickle
down to when they become adults and
perhaps they get into positions of power
and maybe they're going to journalism
and become
become influential in that way or
something um
the way the thing that really really
riled me up was when
everything felt a little bit like a game
it was the individuals to whom
everything felt like
nothing was taken seriously
um because the the subtext of that was i
will be able to either
pay or talk my way out of some sort of a
problem and it all felt
university
and some of the situations kind of all
seemed a bit like
like a summer holiday
to them you know like right i'm just
here for a while like i'll [ __ ] [ __ ] up
i don't really care i don't need to act
virtuously um and you know fortunately i
ended up in
uh living with four other guys i think
all of whom went to private schools but
i was finding the ones that i really
resonated with and there was an equal if
not greater number of
people who had this sort of and you know
you could have people that didn't go to
private school went to state schools but
had quite a privileged upbringing maybe
they were from london perhaps they were
from you know just somewhere that seemed
yeah a little bit more walled off a
little bit more protected and um
they didn't do well like they didn't do
well at university they weren't prepared
well for the world and if they did
manage to get themselves into positions
of of authority or power influence
i wouldn't want that impacting the way
that the country goes like fair play if
you can game the system if you can [ __ ]
around at uni and you can still come out
of it with the the right connections or
the the right degree that gets you into
the right place
like you know more fool anybody that
doesn't do that because you've had tons
of fun
i still don't want to follow you
yeah i still don't want to trust the
things that you say and i still really
really don't want you to be influencing
the culture yes absolutely and i guess
there's an element of
it's not what you know right it's who
you know and and that there's a sort of
i can fall back on daddy's connections
or something like that
and
again this is a sweeping generalization
as i say there are some absolutely
bloody fantastic friends that i've got
who have not had anything like a silver
spoon in their life you know you've got
people that go to these schools that
have been there on scholarships for
example um who
uh i've so much time for in the world
um but
i i think you're right i think there's
an extent to which you think well and
that's what we've seen with trump that's
what we've seen with brexit
to a limited extent i still don't
completely buy that this was just a
rejection of sort of middle-class
technocrats but i think there was a
large extent to which it's saying well
you people have been telling me that you
know what's best for me for goodness
only knows how long
you know since uh
the
in the 90s the clinton set basically
said well
liberalism is what we've achieved and
liberalism is what's going to deliver
for everybody so we as middle class
liberal technocrats will do quite well
in telling you what to do thank you very
much and we get to all the way to 2016
and of course the big divides happen
with brexit and with trump where you've
you've
got people turning around to them and
saying well you've been running the
country
now for x amount of years and how good
of a job would you say you've done
right the financial crash
and all the rest of it
and i'm suffering and my
i'm seeing my livelihood squeezed i'm
seeing that
the things in prices in shops and all
the rest of it are going up but my wages
productivity in this country is not
going up
why is that why are you not doing
anything about this
and
a desire
to actually send a message and actually
have their voice heard i think that's
one thing i've heard more than anything
else over these past few years which is
i
want to actually
feel that i am being listened to that i
the voiceless silent we hear this silent
majority
actually hearing the voices heard for
once
and that i think is a a theme that's
still going on now that's still
resonating with people
and i'm afraid to say that i really
don't think that boris johnson and the
the conservative party at the minute are
doing much in the way of that and and i
think that eventually
boris is sort of bumbling around a bit
like a asda shopping trolley with only
three wheels right i he he doesn't know
his ass from his elbow and
there's no there's no sort of anchor
guiding them you know where you can't
say that about blair you cannot say that
about maggie thatcher you cannot say
that about some of the greatest
politicians that have been in the top
job in this country but they weren't
they weren't going through a global
pandemic that's true that's very true
but i think at this point though where a
majority of people especially those who
are statistically more likely to be
susceptible to the
worst elements of the coronavirus have
been double vaccinated
we're still i think at this point
applying a sort of well there's only one
game in town and it's coronavirus and
actually the only other game in town
despite this government being elected on
a pledge and a promise to level up
seems to be one that's going to achieve
quite the polar opposite that's going to
achieve level and down and that's this
stupid net zero target which i am i can
probably tell you i'm not happy with it
i'm so angry about it who i've got on
the show soon patrick moore
okay yeah co-founder of greenpeace
uh-huh so that's gonna be interesting
yeah he's written a new book and um
he was on trigonometry not long ago
and uh yeah he reached out he's he's
fascinating man but yeah i am
i don't know dude i think the next few
years are going to be are going to be
hopefully quite interesting in in a good
direction
i just think
[ __ ] for me to be the one that's
encouraging people to be skeptical
because i've always been so trusting and
it really does feel like this year has
completely eroded that away and yeah if
we can have more people that are a
little bit
more rational questioning whether or not
this is the right thing for us steady
yeah steady steady this is going to be
darren grimes is
steady anyway darren grimes ladies and
gentlemen people want to check out your
stuff where should they go mate uh they
can just go to darrengrimes.com and all
of the links and everything they need
and all be on there
perfect thanks mate cheers
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace